welcome to this video playing zato
subtle subtle from Finland and think I
love French defence so I'd see him I
quite often play the touch simply
because I feel I can play that without
knowing the theories so well okay yeah
there are obviously many impossible
lines what can also play with m4 and and
something like that yeah the sugar for
sir the main move here and no 94 yeah
there are lines where black even
sacrifice on f3 I don't know is this one
of them and righty to log every year
this might be might be on here okay
let's let's retreat okay maybe it's
another position he seems to know where
the lines play instantly okay 926 so
what's blacks idea maybe night here 25
you know what I want to do is I want to
try and use the e5 square and play
against the pawn I mean one ideas to go
night f1 and obviously he just takes it
so I must prepare g3 Hanks there three
nights of Kim it's not so easy to get
this prepared okay it's probably not so
easy to do so I'm going with an IG three
rookie 195 this type of IDM 10 s
fascinating issue in this position is my
default bond which is really somewhat
weak and can be a source of counter play
like we see here he's taking on deform
what I'm thinking though is what about
bishop age 7 aren't you neglecting the
King side let's plug here Bishop h7 King
age 7 rg5 check King 2g8 queen age 50
yeah I at least I get at least two pawns
and and then attack so much is clear and
there also is the idea to just plain ig5
just the tech on h7 g6 I can take on age
seven witches an immediate kill so nigh
g5 black must play h6 and then maybe
queen age five minutes it that's very
dangerous
you
okay but I'm not seeing a direct with
Neji 5h 6q between age 5 I mean black
might even just take on deform and what
exactly is how am i winning then Queen
g6 black can probably just take the
night don't I don't see em let's see a
mate coming okay so switch to Bishop h7
Bishop age 17 edged up 95 check King g8
Queen h5 yeah the night on d6 is
covering f7 oh that's that's a real
shame let's say look the eight queen age
seven king of eight now I Queen edge AJ
check king is 70 thats thats that's
winning even okay maybe he needs to go
to add cream check
i don't i'm not sure that it is winning
really with rook e8 coming
takes clergy for checking g8 queen age 5
rupee 80 p8 to make it as possible for
the King to go to the aid so Queen h7
check king of it maybe maybe here I need
to I need to find something that
maybe come on let's let's do that here
check at the end I'm going to play it
anyway 95 King g8 Queen h5 rookie aid I
wonder night f5 maybe okay this is chef
necessary anyway I mean I wasn't really
thinking about Queen King g6 because it
looks a queen age 5 King f6 yeah that's
at least not H them if everything else
fails and this is playable okay but King
GA time this is critical anyway Queen h5
rookie 89 f 59 TX f5 the screen takes
the edge checkmate EF rookie one was my
idea blocking those squares so that the
King cannot escape maybe
kingi ate green h5 rookie a night f 59
f5 threatens Queen h7 and 27 winning it
it completely cuts after the flight
squares EF rookie one threatening Queen
h7 queen edge Eden mate
the fop 197 maybe
is he really thinking about King g6 sign
this is hard to believe maybe
now okay let's let's briefly consider
kinky sex queen h5 check King f6 and
well night h7 King moves or I take fhm
at sides probably not not a flat-out win
probably not kingi success there's some
some other moons let's say the check
King f6 is there some other okay of
course I can play Knight h7 check king
of 7s also queen of three check this
wins right h7 King f7 arm ke7 okay so at
least here I I know what to do so rook
e8 rookie a test this is necessary I'll
I think
I don't think other moves on other moves
help no I this is not on I can give the
check and I think night h5 was my idea I
if I give this chick first king is seven
Queen g7 yeah that's also not bad at all
yeah but still that this must be this is
stronger yeah I need to check rookie aid
and see if my intended tonight at five
was working I mean white has a strong
attack in any case but night f5 what's
interesting okay but I don't I don't
think it is this game is not over yet I
mean it's probably not a maid I don't
see what he should do though I mean I'm
just threatening Queen g7 and
yeah and Knight f6 I mean yeah here I
should have 9 f 6 or not the check if I
take on f6 he needs to recapture with
the night and then if I give on a check
on h8 ok that's the snide g8 just not
spectacular but possible if I take on g7
in this position here Nigerian edge edge
checking e7 Queen takes g7 wins all
pieces on
it's not g7 the best things
hmm or if I'm cake I can I can I can
play it play this is a simpler check
king here and then Knight f6 and I'd
have six Queen g7 assess easy and now
probably just here if it takes with the
pawn I have queen age 7 and then after
king d 6 or King d8 let's not f7 and
this runs into an enormous check I'm not
sure what it's doing actually but now
check this is a discovered check but not
sure what it is if it is a winning or
I'm not I don't have a great an
obviously great square to go to
maybe this isn't so clear actually yah
yah i thot 97 and there should be
something but check it's not clear i
mean even King c7 way it's my great
discovered check maybe maybe Queen g8
intending Queen g3 check this maybe I
don't I don't know if I if I check I
mean 95 for example there's probably
really just king a king to Derby eight
and it's not so so clear what it is
actually doing
remarkable
ok
okay I thought Bishop d7 and then give
this check but even that isn't clear not
not entirely maybe Queen g3 check okay
but should be some Queen g3 checking c8
and then maybe I should just I should
just push the H pawn it could be Jackie
do this first so that king must be must
be moving and blocking the oak king c8
king CA to
yeah maybe maybe I should just push the
pawn possible
now you will get the default pawn which
is really not not great
really amazing
oops sort of it's just a discrete size
accidentially okay rook c1 just
preventing 94 you should probably just
take it with the Queen on default and
then I intended to push with with the
edge form I don't really see a somesome
attacker care that I can I can play at
those pieces on d7c 68 they do a good
job in defending you know the sad didn't
expect really strikes me as a bit
passive
okay but the test set has some point of
course maybe you can get to to hear to a
form but still okay I don't want to
trade quinces this is probably nothing
nothing nothing to play for okay I've
got to be fourth or as an idea and still
the H porn going to cannot really use
all its pieces b6 before
yeah maybe instance this again good for
why that I don't know very very tricky
position I think I think you should have
taken on deform
maybe a five has an idea a five Luke a
six activating the rook but yeah I
probably just play h4 h5 h6 and so on
note that this H bond is supported by a
queen and night until he's a bit tight
tight down here tied down or tied up
yeah let's say not lots of well
coordinated okay go before him b4 b5
let's get our King a 70 is the the idea
hmm maybe this wasn't good would have
been better to
to just ignore it I but still I'm
threatening be five year wait wait wait
wait and I'm threatening b5 King a seven
I just go be five
King night last I thought be five here
and then night d6 all 96 immediately in
all 96 hours King 87
okay I don't have so much time left I
can take before and then 96 is not
possible at all oh and oops big oops
yeah yeah now 92 now in addition to all
of that no no that's terrible what the
heck did i do here ah why why did I push
the the queenside point I could just
play h4 h5 h6 and win this easily i
think yeah i'm just blundering the whole
queenside this way
just just great
yeah maybe threatening a five here yeah
that's the nice trick maybe a BF I've
had the Queen doesn't do a job anymore
anymore on g8 annually I need to move it
here Knight d2 that's a five coming yeah
takes b6 and King be a tweener forecheck
winning the night or at least I mean
check that's really not good for black
if five I can also just play 95 here
takes Queen takes King c8 rook c1 check
the atlases must must be must be here
must be good if not then there's
something seriously wrong with the scam
I mean chess overall on a specific game
this must be good for why now don't
don't tell me it isn't takes Queen takes
King see a juke fc1 check yeah it's
winning bishop c6 book c6 at King the
825 check wins the house
I'm not check check Bishop's is six I
can take it that's it at some point I
can take it check queen on a fine
check oh really tough game check
checkmate that was what was stuff let's
much to look at right from this year i
mean i'm pretty sure it is good for
wildwood computer as not not sure and
the computer wants to go to Jesus
exchange interesting and says this is
winning okay and I probably probably
didn't play it the best possible way
here at night at five this idea is this
good computer wants to play rock
everyone with similar interactions what
about this move it is not working here
okay it's not working you too rookie for
aha no Kevin as I didn't see so not sure
but rookie one is winning here
it's bit it's probably threatening night
at five so this is on chat and now here
check the computer is just saying plus
five yeah it's probably just too strong
as a tech night f6 it's a possible
continuation yeah that's probably too
strong poor young okay so check let's
see night h5 via the computer says I'm
completely winning but ok I shall aid
this and this was nonsense okay I saw
this is winning this is what I a saw it
I mean I told you about the move but I
thought the other one is easier and the
thing is that I'm this is the first
important join of course that wins
everything very easily so this is not on
and I'm threatening Queen a jade I mean
this is the the best defense and then
then back this move and everything and
this is winning check okay but I went I
went for this and this problem is really
that I thought okay all night f7 I have
this big check and there is nothing
there's nothing in this amazing I have
no I have no good to discover check at
all check I can even go here now this
the computer says this is good for white
by myth with taking a and then then aged
for now okay but it also it gives some
checker and just here with the draw Chad
yeah this is probably less convincing if
you do it
no so it's simply better coordinated so
here Chen here I don't know I mean maybe
this this i feel is okay but around here
yeah maybe voice is just bad i mean this
is just a bad move and the edge flow is
good probably yeah okay at least the
computer is giving a slight edge for
white so I'm not not like losing but
maybe he needs it needs a bit more time
to a tourist asset more reliably you
know but this is just bad i mean the
Kings is getting out and I'm losing all
the pawns so probably and probably lost
here- foil okay yeah and here he already
spoiled some some of its advantage he
can play Knight a5 here for example and
this is already a bit tricky and this is
losing this is losing he must play
Knight a5 still with an advantage to
black according to the computer but only
one pawn I mean it's already a slightly
unclear I can i git push the Pawnee
again okay 92 and then a 5 here that was
really a really just winning now check
check Joe let's just just chat winning
yeah Bishop c6 I can I this even this
major I had only seen this one oops
check check which of course is winning
as well but ok this is obviously a bit
checkmate a bit quicker and this is chat
also winning easily
yeah this was also not so easy so if it
was it was a bit lucky at the end the
before move was really bad I mean it's
it's a very often the type of move when
you have little time at you you want
this threat sir just threaten something
and it's just not helping at all because
a six it's it opens up this useful King
a seven move and yeah they just just not
them just not good for white alright
hope you enjoyed it very complicated
game thanks for watching